to G Quant a super rich industrialist in
1930s Germany today your family Dynasty
owns Brands like BMW Mercedes-Benz and
in the 1930s you were doing great you
were at the top of your game but then
something unfortunate happens a certain
guy with a small mustache takes over
Germany and with Hitler came a lot of
instability and eventually war and even
though you may not agree with everything
that Hitler says or maybe you do you
don't really care either way you're a
businessman not a politician can't a man
just make a re mark in peace you're not
trying to stir the pot with this new
government you just want to make money
so you do the only thing you can do to
keep your business running you become a
Nazi you publicly buy into Hitler's
vision for the world you donate to his
political party you manufacture his
weapons basically you do the exact same
thing as every American defense
contractor today except you do it for
Hitler and in return you become Hitler's
most beloved Tycoon you receive contract
after contract worth millions of Rights
marks and you were the first in line to
buy what whatever Jewish businesses you
wanted for a fraction of what they were
really worth and the best part about
supporting a dictator is that you got to
use thousands of Jewish laborers in your
factories free labor and once the war
was over even though Germany lost you
found yourself wealthier than ever
before but you're not in the clear yet
because now the Allied Powers were going
after everyone that supported Hitler's
Deeds so if you don't want to spend the
rest of your life in prison or to see
all of your wealth get taken from you
you would have to think fast you would
have to make make it seem like you were
never a Nazi at all you would have to
make everyone forget that you supported
the most evil man on Earth and it was
from this that you pulled off the
greatest rebranding of all time think
about it when you hear the name
Mercedes-Benz today you don't think Nazi
war machine you think luxury class the G
wagon when you hear the name BMW you
also don't think of the Nazi war machine
you think about going to the mechanic
because of how terribly unreliable they
are no one driving your cars today ever
thinks about how they're inadvertently
enriching the families who supported
Hitler every step of the way way and
this is how you pull it off and if
you're thinking right now well this
Quant guy probably died years ago he
can't be holding his family responsible
for what he did well think again because
not only did his family do everything in
their power to hide his Nazi ties from
the public just like he did they're also
not apologizing for any of it and they
are far from the only wealthy German
families like this this video is based
on the book Nazi billionaires the dark
history of Germany's wealthiest
dynasties by David D Jong will link it
below so stay dangerous and let's get
into it
[Music]
it's pretty incredible that the Quan's
family wealth has survived this long
that's because one thing I quickly
realized after meeting a lot of rich
people is that knowing how to make money
is one thing but having the self-control
to not blow it all and actually grow
your wealth is a totally different ball
game and that is why rich people always
always use financial advisors for
example as I started making money I had
no idea whether or not to use a rough
IRA or a 401k or how much money I should
contribute every month I had no idea
what insurance to get and Googling often
led to conflicting answers it would have
been real nice to have a financial
adviser to go to who has a legal
responsibility to act in my best
interest the problem is financial
advisors typically cost2 to $75,000 per
year but luckily that is where domain
money comes in today's paid sponsor for
just $79 a month domain money gives you
your own certified financial adviser who
can help you with your investing savings
Insurance taxes Family Planning all
without hidden fees or investment
minimums basically domain's advisors let
you not stress about your finances so
you can focus on what you're good at for
a tiny fraction of the cost and domain
even has a 6% apy savings account which
is 13 times the national average and
they will prepare and file your taxes
for you so if you want to see if domain
money is right for you click the link
below and match with your financial
guide today scroll down and click the
link below now
born into a wealthy German family in
1881 U Gunther Quant were groomed to
take over the family textile business
from a young age under your leadership
the family business supplied the German
army with uniforms during World War I
which meant that the more the German
soldiers died the more new uniforms the
military would need and so from early on
Germany's loss became the Quant game but
you weren't satisfied with just one big
win you have bigger dreams for yourself
and none of them included being just
somewhat wealthy you wanted to be a
magnet a tycoon you wanted everyone in
Germany to know your name but to do that
you would have to expand and luckily you
had the perfect opportunity by the time
World War I was over and the Great
Depression was around you were already
swimming in money so as thousands of
businesses across Europe went under you
stood ready inflated cash and
wheelbarrow to buy them all up and as
the years went on you just became more
and more obsessed you were so focused on
money and nothing else that in 1929 your
wife Magna decided that she had had
enough and asked you for a divorce
taking your son Herold with her and
that's where your first interest in the
Nazi party was sparked you see Magda
didn't waste any time finding herself a
new husband in September 1930 she
attended a party meeting where a man
named Joseph gobl spoke gobl was one of
Hitler's closest friends and would later
become the chief of the Nazis propaganda
department and for Magna it was love at
first sight over the next few months she
went out of her way to get close with
gobl and by mid 1931 they got engaged
and as magna's ex-husband you can help
but be interest Ed in the beliefs of the
new man she was marrying and as one of
the richest businessmen in Germany you
had caught Hitler's attention too see
before Hitler became the leader of
Germany he didn't have a ton of money
lying around to use for his campaign and
party he needed outside funding and who
better to go to than the rich German
businessmen who liked his views so in
February 1931 you were invited to meet
Hitler for the first time you were one
of dozens of businessmen Hitler asked
for money from and even though you
didn't see any harm in offering Hitler a
few million R marks you honestly didn't
think he would make it that far quote I
can't say that Hitler made a significant
or meaningless a sympathetic or
repulsive impression on me he struck me
as perfectly average end quot to you
later wrote but in just a few short
years you would be very impressed at
just how high Hitler would
[Music]
climb as magda's ex-husband people
assumed that you would be the last
person to want to get involved in her
wedding with Joseph Gobles but they were
wrong Magda may have been your ex but in
her new marriage you saw opportunity
opportunity to get close to Hitler see
by late 1931 you had realized that
Hitler wasn't just some wantanabe
politician he was really gaining
supports maybe getting on his good side
wouldn't be such a bad idea after all so
when Magda and gobl announced their
plans to get married you didn't just
offer them your congratulations you
actually invited them to host their
wedding on on your family estates how
generous right it was a genius move
because Joseph goal's best man turned
out to be none other than Hitler himself
putting you right back on his radar as
the only logical Rich German he could
trust and turn to for help over the next
year you kept growing your relationship
with Hitler in Secrets the Nazi party
hadn't won any elections yet and you
weren't about to gamble your reputation
in business on a maybe but you wouldn't
keep it a secret for very long because
in 1933 Hitler actually did it he became
chancellor of Germany the equivalent of
president or prime minister and with the
Nazi party in power there was no need to
hide your support anymore so shortly
after Hitler took over you officially
became a member of the Nazi party and
when Hitler announced that he would be
rearming Germany in violation of the
agreement it signed after World War I
you were one of the first companies in
line to receive those contracts guns
ammunition uniforms and batteries were
just some of the few things you produce
and sold to the German military by 1937
Hitler appointed you as one of the
leaders of Germany's military economy
meaning that you were now one of the
rich businessmen approved and trusted by
the new German government and with this
new title and influence you expanded
your business more than ever before but
just as you were reaching the peak of
your money power and influence World War
II broke out and while the war was
horrifying for some for you all you saw
was one giant
opportunity
you already knew just how profitable War
could be after making millions during
the first world war but back then you
had just been a regular businessman in
charge of a regular company but now you
were part of Hitler's Chosen Few his
inner circle of businessmen who were
offered every contract and deal first
and nothing could have prepared you for
the amount of money you would be making
over the next 6 years one of your first
big contracts was for weapons bullets
rifles pistols the man for the these
basic wartime supplies was so high that
within a few months the stock price for
your weapons company would shoot up by
300% another one of your companies AFA
went the same way as a battery
manufacturer AFA was contracted to sell
thousands of batteries to the German
military for its submarines Torpedoes
and Rockets and then there were the good
old uniforms just like in World War I
your company was chosen to supply German
soldiers with their distinctive Nazi
uniforms and with more than 17 million
soldiers having joined the German
military by 1945 yor offers were
overflowing and as gunwant you could
have stopped here you were already rich
powerful and successful Beyond Your
Wildest Dreams everyone in Germany knew
your name but like most people who
profit from war you just got greedy as
the war raged on you started hearing
stories of other German businessmen
taking over Jewish companies and making
them their own and you just couldn't
resist the temptation and so you and
your son Herbert Quant got to work over
the 6 years of World War II thousands of
successful Jewish people were forced to
flee Europe to finance their escape many
of of them chose to sell their companies
to Germans before they left and since
most of the Jewish people were desperate
to leave you could easily buy up
companies for a fraction of what they
were actually worth Jewish people were
forced to sell their businesses for an
80% discount the Germans called this
type of hostile takeover aryanization
and it happened all over Europe in the
1930s and 40s but even this was not the
worst thing you did either because
before the war ended you would make one
more move that was cement your
reputation as one of Europe's most
brutal
[Music]
businessmen
as more and more Germans were forced to
enlist in the Army German businesses
including yours were facing a labor
shortage but luckily for you you knew
just where to get a steady supply of
cheap or even free workers the Jewish
camps obviously over the next 6 years of
World War II you would use around 50,000
forced labor in your weapons factories
and as you can imagine the conditions
were so bad that we can't get into
specifics without getting demonetized
needless to say this was a psychotically
profitable move but all good things must
come to an end and yours finally did in
1945 when Hitler alleged took his own
life marking the end of World War II for
the past 12 years you held on to the
hope that maybe Hitler would actually
win and you would be able to enjoy your
spoils in peace time but now the allies
and the Soviet Union controlled Germany
which meant that you needed a save face
so you flipped you and your sons Herbert
and Harold did everything in your power
to hide your Nazi party membership you
told everyone who would listen to you
that you had always disapproved of the
party's plans but that just wasn't
enough in 1946 you were arrested for
your participation in Germany's War
efforts and so you blamed it all on
Joseph gobl you said that he had forced
you to join the party and that he was
framing you you were completely
Innocents but little did you know that
Joseph gobl had already died from the
war along with your ex-wife and their
six children it wasn't a good look it
looked like you would spend the rest of
your life in jail but somehow you got
lucky less than a year after your arrest
you were released according to the judge
you may have been a Nazi party member
but you actually didn't take an active
part in any of the crimes well if only
they knew free at last you took control
of the Quant family Dynasty again and
then you trained your two sons Herbert
and Herold to take over once you died
both Herbert and heral have been
complicit in your crimes Herbert even
helped plan and build one of those
famous camps in Poland while hero served
in the German air force throughout World
War II but unlike you your sons weren't
as well known which meant fewer people
knew of their dark past in 1955 Gunther
Quan died on holiday in Egypt the
weapons manufacturing side of the
company went to Herold while the rest of
the business was left to Herbert the son
who has supported him through it all
forc labor and camps included and just
like Gunther Herbert had Big Dreams for
his family's
[Music]
business
while Gunther Quant was making billions
from the war another company was doing
just as well BMW for most of the 1930s
and 40s BMW has switched from a car and
motorcycle manufacturer to a makeshift
weapons producer like the quants BMW
realized that the real money in any war
was in the guns and ammo and just like
the quants BMW was more than happy to
use forced labor in his factories maybe
they bonded over their love for free
forc labor or they bonded over their
deep Nazi Roots but when BMW ran out of
money in 1960 Herbert Quant was the
first man they turned to like his dad
Herbert knew an opportunity when he saw
it and so in 1960 he and the rest of the
Quant family became majority
shareholders in BMW over the next few
years Herbert would transform BMW into
one of the most successful car
manufacturers in the world he would also
use all his money and influence to
ensure that no one ever found out about
his questionable past and surprisingly
it worked when you have enough money to
buy up news companies bribe researchers
and make entire history books disappear
refurbishing the truth becomes easy for
decades Herbert and Herold were allowed
to enjoy all their ill-gotten gains in
peace and when they eventually died
their children simply took over where
they left off with a net worth of over
$8 billion while pretending that they
have no idea what their father and
grandfather have done but they couldn't
escape forever in 2007 a documentary
film about the Quant crimes was released
to the public and all around the world
people were Furious the two Quant Harris
Stefan and suzan were straight up
Germany's wealthiest family so as damage
control the two quants commissioned an
independent study into their family's
history but when the research came back
confirming everything the documentary
said they didn't really seem to care
either all Stefan had to say was that
they were distancing themselves from
their father and grandfather and that
doing so was massive and painful
obviously how sorry can they really feel
about what their family did but it
didn't matter anyways because by the
time the Quant family was exposed BMW
was already one of the biggest car
manufacturers on Earth same thing with
Mercedes-Benz and so that's it that is
how you get away with being part of one
of the most evil war machines ever but
the worst part is that the Quant family
is far from
[Music]
alone this is ferdinan Porsche many
people know him as the genius engineer
behind one of the world's best car
brands but what they don't realize is
that like Gunther Quant ferin and
Porsche jumped at the chance to work for
Germany's murderer and Chief and he
didn't care who he had to backstab in
the process in 1933 Hillary gave a
speech praising Germany's car designers
and Engineers as Geniuses in response
Ferdinand Porsche personally sent Hitler
a telegram saying that he and his staff
were ready to put quote their will and
ability at the disposal of the German
people end quotes and so Hitler put them
to work while still producing their
special brand of racing cars Porsche was
also tasked with designing and building
the first Volkswagen Hitler's Vision was
to produce a German car for the German
people at a low cost of less than a
th000 wretch marks or about $8,200 to
day but there was just one problem the
co-founder of porch's company was Jewish
a guy named Adolf Rosenberger who had
been their main financial backer and
there was no way Hitler was going to put
his stamp of approval on a car with any
ties to the Jewish people but luckily
ferin had an easy fix while Hitler was
going after the Jewish people
Rosenberger had decided to moved to
America while he still could so Porsche
and his son-in-law Anton offered to buy
their old friend and partner out of the
company and as expected Ferdinand porch
had all the leverage he knew Rosenberger
was in no position to negotiate so he
offered to buy Rosenberger out of the
company for pennies on the dollar the
Rosenberger it was either take the deal
and live or risk getting killed so the
choice was obvious feran gave
Rosenberger shares to his son FY and so
in 1935 Porsche finally became a 100%
German company ready to carry out
Hitler's orders fairy porch porch even
went so far as to voluntarily join the
SS the equivalent of Hitler's Secret
Service and if that wasn't enough just
like the quants Porsche jumped at the
chance to use cheap Force labor in their
factories once the war started andon
Porsche's son-in-law said he didn't have
a choice he said he had to resort to
force labor if the company ever wanted
to produce Hitler's Volkswagen for that
insanely cheap price he didn't think
about the fact that many of those forc
laborers were also Mass producing
weapons for the German Army at the time
so when World War II ended Ferdinand
fairy and Anton all ended up in jail for
their ties to the German war machine FY
the guy who actually joined the SS got
out after just 6 months and took back
control of his father's company later
Anton and fan would get out too but with
Germany losing and Hitler long gone the
portion of Volkswagen companies would
also have to do some serious rebranding
but luckily they rebranded so well that
today the fury Porsche Foundation is one
of the biggest donors to the University
of Stuart Germany where the history
Department of that University released a
study on Porsche's Nazi past that
happens to leave a lot of the family's
crimes out today the history of the
Porsche brand is something most Germans
choose to ignore considering the Porsche
family Now controls car brands like aie
Bentley and Lamborghini
too dozens of German families like the
Quant and Porsches made their fortunes
thanks to Hitler in World War II and
even though America and Britain made a
big show of arresting and punishing them
for their crimes they didn't bring as
many of these families to justice as you
may think most of you know about
Operation Paperclip after World War II
the US brought over a bunch of Nazi
officers and scientists to help them win
the Cold War but what you may not know
is that Britain was even worse see long
before World War I and 2 Europe's
wealthy families all kind of knew each
other the British families would do
business with the German ones they would
go to the same ski resorts attended the
same events their kids probably went to
the same schools too so when it came
time for the British to identify and put
punish German dynasties that benefited
from the Nazi party they just didn't
they would even go out of their way to
make sure their friends who were
arrested were set free and since the
British who were supposed to be
Germany's biggest enemy were literally
vouching that these families were
innocent everyone just kind of accepted
that they probably were so the same
Hitler supporters that should have spent
the rest of their lives in jail they got
to keep their companies they got to keep
their money and they got to keep their
influence over the German economy and
governments today none of these families
have really owned up to what their
grandparents did or have tried to do
right with the families they hurt the
best they could do was add a few lines
on the company's websites talking about
how they deeply regret what their
grandparents had to do in their
situation and you want to know who else
might have got away with it Hiller see
the official narrative is that Hitler
took his own life in his bunker as
Berlin was getting captured by the
Soviets and that the Soviets found his
dead body shortly after and that's it
Hitler is confirmed dead but did you
know that no one actually ever saw
Hitler's dead body did you know that
even his close Associates only ever saw
a body roll up in a rug with only the
top of his head and shoes showing did
you know that Hitler notoriously had
used more than 24 body doubles to stand
in for him at events and that one body
double was even shot and killed by
Soviet soldiers and was actually
mistaken for Hitler for a while before
anyone got a good look at him did you
know that the piece of skull that the
Soviets claimed to be Hitler's was
actually identified by DNA test to
belong to a woman in 2009 did you know
that after the war the FBI was spending
millions of dollars a year sending FBI
agents all over the world to find out if
Hitler was in fact dead and that in 2017
a set of heavily redacted FBI documents
were Declassified with one of the
documents being a report from a man who
allegedly helped six top Argentinian
officials bring Hitler to Argentina via
submarine so if you consider all of that
the question becomes isn't it reasonable
to assume that a man like Hitler with
his motivations and his resources would
have planned to fake his own death and
if he did survive where did he go how
did he escape the answer to these
questions lies possibly in South America
well today there are straight up German
towns with German architecture and
German cultural festivals filled with
descendants of former Nazis and now
we're removed 70 to 80 years from the
facts it has been painful to try to use
real science real investigative tools to
try to sift through this lore studying
this for how long now three years three
years if you if you had a guess if you
had like a million bucks you got to put
it on one side or another did he go
there yeah and we investigate it all in
our new private documentary that you can
watch right now by clicking the card on
the screen this documentary is part of
our YouTube membership where we post
documentaries that are too controversial
to be posted publicly and we've got a
ton of great ones out already these
documentaries will never be posted
anywhere else you are going to love this
one on Hitler's death and you can watch
it right now by clicking the card on the
screen stay dangerous and we'll see you
in the next
one